welcome back to las vegas now he is
considered by his peers to be the
greatest stage magician of the past
century and he's returning to the las
vegas stage for a special show
benefiting you have a hair on your dress
though oh my gosh he's already getting
started everybody he's already getting
started it is the lance burton in the
show it's benefiting opportunity village
and variety of children's charity of
southern nevada so it is our pleasure to
welcome you sir to the stage welcome to
las vegas rocky i had to welcome you on
live tv now now you're welcoming me
because you're no stranger to las vegas
i lived here almost 40 years wow and uh
i worked my first job was at the follies
brought here at the tropicana hotel was
there nine years been five years at the
hacienda hotel that just before your
time right right
that hotel's gone and then 14 years at
the monte carlo hotel oh here's some
clips from some of my some shows and my
tv specials and things wow and then a
little over a year ago you know i got
into my retirement full-time and i moved
back to my farm in kentucky and how has
that been for you i have been having a
time in my life i i get up and and and i
walk my dog and and we have cows and
wide open spaces and it's so peaceful
and quiet well no pun intended but it
sounds magical but
thank you
until uh about two or three weeks ago
then i went out on the road and i've
been doing a series of shows and the big
finale is saturday night here in las
vegas boom and when you said when you
drove into town you saw the lights again
you felt like you were home yeah back
home right
last night as i drove we were coming
from uh bend oregon and we drove through
and we came through trump and as we got
over to the top of the hill i saw the
lights of las vegas and i got that same
thrill that the first time i saw las
vegas when i was in my early 20s i can
imagine that so let's talk about lance
burton and friends what can we expect in
the show well
27 saturday it's it's on on saturday
night and it's at opportunity village uh
oaky
campus it's a benefit for opportunity
village and for variety children's
charity of southern nevada two
organizations that are near and dear to
my heart i've been working with them
since the 1980s wow before you were born
oh come on
come on i got 89. i'm an 80s i get to
claim 80s baby okay
and the show is uh my new show is lance
burton and friends so i do about half
the show with illusions and sleight of
hand magic and audience participation
and my friends are fielding west the
great comedy magician michael goudeau
comedy juggler who was who was my guest
star in my show for for almost 20 years
in las vegas and keith west and the
illusioneers and so it's a it's a show
for the whole family it's going to be
good okay speaking of audience
participation i am your audience can you
do help me with the trick could you set
your ipad down yeah i can and what i
need you to do is you're going to be my
lovely assistant you're just going to
hold this envelope here like this that's
it and perfect and i will pull
these cards out and i will set them
right on top now rocky this is a test of
your imagination i want you to imagine
as long as i'm not doing math no this is
real easy imagine there are four playing
cards there now that's the easy part
there are four cards but imagine they're
the four
queens now that would be a good hand if
we were down on the strip yeah that
would be great if i were to reach in
there and remove two of the queens in
your imagination which two did i remove
i'll give you a hint these two are the
same color so they could be black or
they could be red
but they're queens they're queens so did
i remove the black ones or the red ones
you removed the red ones the red ones
that is exactly right the queen of
diamonds and the queen of hearts as you
can plainly see folks
now here rocky here we go now's where it
gets tricky queen of hearts queen of
diamonds i'm going to mix them up so you
don't know which is which okay hearts
and diamonds i'm going to place them
back i'm going to turn one upside down
which queen did i turn upside down in
your imagination the queen of diamonds
the queen of diamonds so in other words
what you're saying is the card that is
upside down yeah would be the queen of
diamonds now rocky
i don't want you to think that that was
some sort of sleight of hand trick that
i somehow flipped that card over at the
last second that's why i brought the
queen of diamonds from a different
colored deck in fact i didn't even bring
the other queens
which just goes to show
you have a great imagination you feel
something there in that envelope don't
you i do you do that is
a dvd of my new movie
billy topic master magician available on
amazon that's a gift for you for helping
thank you from deland i appreciate that
that well that was cool i feel like i'm
also a magician today now you're you're
you're a full-fledged magician so
everybody in the audience will feel
like their imagination maybe maybe rocky
will be performing saturday night i love
it so tell people how they can get
tickets you can go to my website
lanceburton.com and there's a link there
that will take you right to
the place to buy tickets and you can
also get them on the opportunity village
website you can buy tickets for the
lance burton show and for entrance into
the magical forest
make a night out of it with the whole
family all right well thank you lance
and thank you for what you're doing for
the communities you're my pleasure thank
you and it's so good to be back home i
just want to say i missed you all this
last year and i love everyone in las
vegas and god bless you all and thank
you for all you've done for me over
there
thank you lance dylan i'll send it to
you my